en el vídeo anterior vimos cómo calcular
el tiempo que tarda en despegar este
avión a 380 teniendo como datos la
velocidad de despegue y la aceleración
ahora en lo que hiciera lo que quisiera
yo saber es qué tan larga debe ser la
pista para que este avión pueda despegar
lo que es una pregunta muy importante si
ustedes quieren construir una pista que
permita que al menos este tipo de
aviones a 380 puedan despegar cuál será
la longitud mínima para esta pista bueno
nosotros sabemos que el desplazamiento
es la multiplicación o bueno va a ser el
resultado de multiplicar la velocidad
por el tiempo pero en este caso nuestra
velocidad no es constante nuestra
velocidad está cambiando este durante el
tiempo entonces no podríamos usar este
dato directamente sin embargo nosotros
tenemos esta aceleración pero esta
aceleración tiene la particularidad de
que es constante
y cuando tenemos una aceleración
constante si y sólo si tenemos
aceleración constante entonces podemos
encontrar o calcular algo llamado
velocidad promedio
entonces como calculamos la velocidad
promedio nuestra velocidad promedio que
sigue siendo un vector va a ser igual a
el promedio de mi velocidad final
menos
mi velocidad inicial y bueno como son
dos elementos o dos cantidades pues el
promedio de estos dos va a ser dividido
vas a dividir esta operación este
resultado entre dos entonces mi
velocidad promedio
tengo que bueno la velocidad final de la
encontramos por aquí en 78 metros por
segundo
metros por segundo
- mi velocidad inicial bueno partimos
del entendido de que es que están desde
cero desde que está detenida entonces
menos cero entre dos así que mi
velocidad promedio de 78 entre 2 resulta
ser 39 metros por segundo
entonces ahora sí con este dato de la
velocidad promedio
lo puedo multiplicar
con
el cambio en el tiempo y así entonces
puedo calcular el desplazamiento
si queremos ver esto o entenderlo de
otra manera vamos a ver una forma un
poco más gráfica vamos a graficar aquí
la velocidad con respecto al tiempo este
es mi eje debe de perdón de tiempo este
es mi eje de velocidad y si yo tengo una
aceleración constante este voy a tener
esta gráfica más o menos
de esta manera va a ser una aceleración
constante por lo que se va a incrementar
así más o menos en este ángulo esto es
una línea recta aunque mi pulso no es lo
mejor esta mañana entonces si yo tengo
que este inicio desde cero y aquí mi
tiempo de despegue es 78 segundos en
este punto es cuando mi avión tiene la
velocidad suficiente para despegar y
vamos a ver que también pues desde
y la velocidad
si comienzo desde cero y alcanzó mi
velocidad de despegue es de 78 metros
por segundo
pues aquí también se va alcanzar en este
punto y a partir de aquí bueno lo habían
ya des despega del suelo
si yo calculará el área bajo esta curva
si yo calculará esta área va a resultar
que esta área va a ser igual a la
distancia que se necesita recorrer para
que este avión pueda despegar
en otro vídeo vamos a ver cuál es el
porqué de esta gráfica al menos darles
una idea un poco más general este de
bueno porque el área bajo la curva de la
aceleración esto es la aceleración
me va a ser igual a la distancia
cuando yo estoy trabajando con la
velocidad promedio que recordamos bueno
calculamos la velocidad promedio es la
mitad o el punto intermedio entre de mi
velocidad inicial y mi velocidad final
que viene siendo más o menos por acá
si yo uso esta velocidad promedio este
dato hasta esta el tiempo necesario para
el despegue si yo calculo el área bajo
esta curva
o bajo esta línea de la velocidad
promedio va a ser exactamente el mismo
la misma área que la que se encuentra
con esta aceleración desde una velocidad
que está cambiando desde cero hasta la
velocidad final y es por eso que bueno
esta velocidad promedio me sirve para
calcular el desplazamiento o la
distancia ahora regresando los números
tenemos que entonces qué
tengo mi desplazamiento que es igual mi
velocidad para medio el acabo calcular a
39 metros sobre segundo el
desplazamiento en el tiempo lo calculó a
78 segundos y saco mi calculadora hago
mis operaciones
39 x 78 y esto me da igual a 3 mil 42
aquí escribo entonces mi desplazamiento
es igual a 3 mil 42 aquí estos segundos
se van
me quedan metros así que la distancia
para que esté bien pueda despegar la
pista debe de medir más de 3000 metros
que es más de 3 kilómetros para que este
avión pueda
bolas para que pueda despegar lo que
encuentro en verdad fascinante